[Music]
what happened what the [ __ ] just
happened right now
i'm sorry joe you really flinched
you really i'm [ __ ] ticklish you
really got a sensitive butthole you know
what it is this guy's stuck and then i
lifted it and i'm the strongest man in
the world dude i deadlifted this [ __ ]
i'm gonna make a note to keep that in
because because it wasn't recording i'm
gonna make a note to keep that in oh my
god
note to self don't show your butt to
barf dude
from bart touching his ass hey man don't
title with that
i poked them in the hamstring insertion
[Laughter]
you did that's a big time flinch bro
honestly
that's that's the ticklish [ __ ] i'm
talking about the table you are ticklish
dude shut up dude that's delicious shut
up take it back
[ __ ] watch your mouth i never need to
tickle you now because part of why you
tickle someone to see if they're
ticklish now we already know no it's
like it's a deadlift tables oh yeah true
dude my fanny pack got in the way that
was uh mostly
oh man
get ready to be mad nick you're gonna
love this guy i don't know talking about
a st louis restaurant fights back
against a food blogger who made heavy
negative reviews after being denied a
discount for posting the content i saw
this [ __ ]
he tried to extort him right he
basically tried to extort him yeah
so there's this dude um his name is
antonio eats l.a
oh i love his blog really you follow him
no
so here's the text that he sent this
restaurant in st louis before visiting
he says
hello i wanted to record the food being
made and posted on my page in exchange
for 100
off the food i can come today 100
who these guys think they are dude yeah
so
let me use you for content and then you
pay me too so the restaurant replied
saying thank you for your offer but i
don't think this collaboration will work
for us that's all he said it's so funny
because we do food content but it's like
the [ __ ]
who does it that way you know right so
then he goes in there and he um
he he still goes orders food and then he
posts on his uh socials saying these are
the worst dumplings ever using a
vomiting emoji saying it has a floral
taste and for the taro dumplings he
wrote that they taste like ass
this guy is really eloquent with this
food that would have sold me
you were hoping for that i mean
tasting like ass is a positive thing for
me
yeah so the restaurant decided to like
fight back by posting what he initially
said to them
and to be like hey like a food blogger
with a lot of followers could mean a lot
of damage to like a small business a
nice restaurant so we have to do
everything we can to you know
um and they wanted to you know give a
voice to other restaurants in the asian
community that are victimized by these
types of bloggers yeah predatory
bloggers bro predatory bloggers that
sounds like extortion to me what's this
what's this blogger's name antonio eats
l.a
so this guy made his ig private after
all this like [ __ ] flak and then he's
probably got all of asia right now going
you son of a [ __ ] [ __ ] you well yeah
because nobody [ __ ] already likes
these guys you know what i mean like
nobody at least in the business unless
you know like it's like you were saying
everyone [ __ ] likes food man you're
not discovering something
[ __ ] foodie yeah yeah yeah we get it
dude you act like an exclusive club but
everyone does this every day i'm kind of
a foodie
right so let me um he did
private his ig you act like you're the
only one that eats food you son of a
[ __ ]
but then he wrote some people do this
more than three times a day
damn he has 200 000 followers for being
a dick
wow
he's a food curator he loves who dude is
he a ig food blogger oh he took it he
took it off he took it off his bio but
on his private page his bio he changed
it to say i would never take money for a
positive review
uh privating my ig due to death threats
death threats this was a [ __ ] hit
someone's trying to kill a hamburger
reviewer this guy
oh man you're a little [ __ ] man antonio
eats l.a i wonder if i follow him i
follow a couple of like food people yeah
but they're not doing that this [ __ ]
yeah see if he uh follow him and see if
he uh
requests i mean he's just one of those
people that probably you know like
there's a lot of good food bloggers and
they're probably just like [ __ ] this
guy's making us look like i mean we've
been paid from restaurants to like
review or come eat or whatever
but no one ever says like
it has to be positive or good but i
always felt weird about saying like hey
i want to come review your restaurant
give me a discount like in exchange if
they're asking me fine yeah but then how
much is a [ __ ] meal like 20 bucks and
it's like a boba tea place isn't it
is it like a dumpling place yeah
dumpling and bubble noodles and bubble
tea yeah yeah if it's a mom and pop too
like the margins
it's like five percent i mean it's just
pretty obvious that if you
were the person to propose your review
and you were asking for a discount it is
now a tainted review no matter what you
say that's true so that's the point
they're trying to make they're like okay
[ __ ] if the dumplings really taste
like ass whatever but like it does now
you've canceled your own review out your
credibility's gone because you started
this and said hey for a hundred dollars
off i'll come in there and i'll do this
thing he might be lying about all these
other places yeah like is he really
gonna get a discount and say oh it
smells like ass in here [ __ ] sucks
yeah that would be hilarious but i
highly doubt that he's
dumplings [ __ ] suck yeah so the
restaurant's called corner 17 they're in
st louis uh they posted a caption saying
we understand that we have a small
platform here in social media and we
don't get as much voice as other
influencers especially with asian
cuisine most of the time restaurants
don't have social accounts or time to
manage an intentionally bad ride up from
a large falling influencer because of
our refusal to accept their collab is
unprofessional and a such hostile manner
can simply ruin their businesses
defu came all the way from la to eat at
a small restaurant in st louis he lives
in st louis and l.a oh he goes back and
forth yeah this was a whack-ass
[ __ ]
yeah in his bio does he have st louis
and then a airplane emoji to l.a
i like that well he doesn't have [ __ ] on
there now because it's private i should
do that all the states yeah yeah people
be like
l-v-h-i-l-a you know ukraine fight too
yeah ukraine flag yeah yeah
like you would think back in the day
when like there were like food critics
right yeah like i'm thinking about
ratatouille and [ __ ] like that you know
what i mean it's like i'm gonna show up
whenever you get you to just be ready if
you know who you are right and i'm not
i'm not showing up but you better give
this to me free but if i know who that
critic is and i'm a restaurant i'm like
we he's here we better make sure it's
good it's not even about like them
transacting like you better [ __ ] pay
me a discount right it's just a matter
of like respect for yourself or if you
respect the critic you know what i'm
saying so to be able to like go out
there and be a [ __ ] influencer and to
like start those conversations and kind
of corner somebody who doesn't [ __ ]
do that [ __ ]
is literally
like the weakest stuff yeah well that's
like when i'm watching kitchen
nightmares and i'm always like damn the
ship's really working hard for gordon
but he probably wouldn't do that for me
at all
sucks
sucks to be me he wants his
validation unless he found luna because
of you hey not bad he doesn't need luna
yeah so a bunch of people are uh now
leaving positive reviews on quarter 17's
restaurant yelp and everything just now
but uh yeah i wonder how many other
[ __ ] do this because like
even even bart you you have stories of
small micro influencers coming in and
saying you know who i am you should let
me in this [ __ ] gym for free well
yeah here i hear i hear stories from
like from the gym staff of like people
trying to come in and like big time you
know and then they're like name their
names i don't even know their names but
they don't have five thousand cause like
the crazy thing is like the people that
are actually big they just pay they just
they're just like oh cool we're
supporting each other we're all in the
fitness game so they're like we'll just
you know like they don't even make them
they don't make they don't hit me up
like hey i'm in town can you hook me up
like i'll just see later on oh sure you
should let me know you know it'd be like
they just do it but then they'll they'll
be people like that and then they'll
they'll like oh you know why i'm here
just they'll like literally show up to
the front desk with like their instagram
did you see that
i could make you guys famous yeah yeah
or infamous if i choose if i so choose
i have the power even in my market where
i where i have the studios
all day long there's gonna be some
influencer that's like hey i have this
many followers can i shoot there for
free can i do this and that and it's
like dude what the [ __ ] like so guess
what price just went up [ __ ] wait it
just doesn't it doesn't help me out at
all
like because all of my customers are
influencers with big followings right
and if i could explain the market like
if i could explain how this works it's
like nobody is going to want to shoot
here more because an influencer shot for
free like that doesn't
it doesn't translate that way i know
people think it does that like oh
so-and-so shot here like it would have
[ __ ] natalie portman shot here yeah
but not another instagramer you know
what i mean like it's got to be like so
what's crazy is that natalie portman
came she'd probably shut down the whole
place for a week and pay you like 10x
the amount and that's exactly what
happens that's the main thing is that
she's here so you're telling me
[Laughter]
i go into buildings if natalie port has
been there i can tell you that the main
people that do pay the most money
are people that normally you would
discount yeah because it's like oh thank
you for shooting here but those people
are like they understand like no i'm not
a [ __ ] bum like yeah i'm gonna pay
for it plus it's not like i'm a [ __ ]
corporation i'm a small business too
just like corner 17. that's not a
[ __ ] you know it's not a chain
2500 location don't touch it going on
mcdonald's though
i know who has this kind of money it's
like hey mcdonald's mcdonald's i don't
know if you know this but i have i'm
gonna take 1200 followers i'm just
[ __ ] big and tasty
this makes me want to reach out to these
guys and be like i'm coming to smell
your chairs just so you know i'm coming
from all the chairs antonio l.a was
dining interesting i'm trying to smell
that chair obviously like we none of us
[ __ ] know this food blogger but it
kind of makes me feel like maybe people
really like when he talks [ __ ] about
restaurants too he might be one of those
guys oh
oh yeah those food critics like the
drama of food and [ __ ] that might be his
demo too so then you can kind of
understand like okay if he's doing that
maybe that's kind of where he sees his
but going in there to [ __ ] just bring
down small businesses yeah what a
[ __ ] dude and then to make your
business rise out of it you're not some
like [ __ ] dark knight who's trying to
help other citizens exactly you're
capitalizing off of taking somebody else
down it's literally the [ __ ] most
pathetic [ __ ] but he still goes and he
still pays for it that's the thing
so he's eating it just to talk [ __ ] and
also like when you go into a
relationship like this don't you want to
lead with like hey let's all be cool
first you know like let's all have let's
all be amicable let's let's make sure
everybody gets some benefit out of this
that's why i'm glad that uh the
community has corner 17's back because
it's like dude you can't keep [ __ ]
with places man like luckily for corner
17 and next shark and just whole like
networks of people that are like all
right you're not gonna [ __ ] with us but
then there's some mom and pop places
that don't know one other person you
know what i love about this we've been
talking [ __ ] on this dude the whole time
and stuff but what if we all go there
and the dumplings taste like ash
and we want so bad to say it we can't
say it though could social media destroy
us and then we're like but they really
do taste like butt somehow i don't know
how they did it but also though if we go
it'll be all good because we never we
didn't hit him with that dumbass pitch
of like we'll pay for it we'll pay for
it yeah we're like hey paid full price
tastes like crap like that guy that guy
was still a dick but the dumplings taste
like i'm like
[Laughter]
he's like do you like it uh it's kind of
assy
[Music]
[Music]
you